hey everyone this is Kevin from the
chesswebsite.com and today we're going
to be going over the slav Geller Gambit
now it starts out in the slab defense so
D4 D5 and then after the Queen's game at
the most popular opening in chess was C4
black plays the slob with
C6 now play typically continues with
Knight F3 Knight F6 and then Knight C3
black has quite a few options but in
this particular video we're going to be
looking at the accepted line taking the
pawn on C4 now there's lots of different
ways for white to respond the main line
is to play A4
stopping the pawn coming to B5 or
playing you know E3 instead just
solidifying the pawn chain preparing for
the bishop to come to C4 again it could
be protected if black wants to play B5
but then eventually trying to get this
material back but Geller Gambit says you
know what we're try something a little
bit different if we're giving up that
pawn to material we're not going to
focus on it right away instead we're
going to try to control the center of
the board and really put our opponent to
the test and that is with the move
E4 now black almost always is going to
hold on to this material C4 that's what
they were going to do anyway
so especially if we're playing E4
they're usually going to play B5 now the
best move from White is to play Bishop
E2 and this is what we're going to be
looking at today the variations form
black that we may see in this one could
be G6
preparing Defiance of the bishop to G7
Castle on the king side that's one
option we're also going to be looking at
B4 just pushing on the queen set the
board attacking this Knight trying to
put white to the test and then we're
also going to be looking at Bishop to B7
saying you know what let's hone in on
this light Square diagonal White's went
ahead and played this E4 but what if
black counter attacks on the center
light squares what happens then so those
are the three options first option we
are going to look at is this Pawn to G6
now as soon as they play this I like to
be extremely aggressive yes you could
cast on the king side if you wanted to
but we already see that they're Queen
said the board
is pretty weak as far as the pawn
structure the black's not going to be
castling on the queen side anytime soon
and so when we play when we see G6 here
white can be pretty aggressive they
already have control the center with the
two pawns here on D4 in E4 and I like to
push forward with H4
once we play H4 we've already said we're
not as interested in castling on the
king side we absolutely could castle if
we wanted to but this says we don't
necessarily have to so just keep that in
mind because it'll come up later in the
video on why this is different than
another variation that we look at
now how could they continue one they
could just keep playing you know Bishop
G7 saying I don't really care too much
about this uh Pawn on H4 or they could
say you know what okay if you're gonna
attack on the king side I'm gonna attack
on the queen side with B4 so let's look
at the first option and that is Bishop
G7 I think this is the worst of the two
options because we're just gonna
continue to push and attack we can start
with E5 we always have this E5 move
after we've played E4 in lots of the
variations we're going to look at maybe
they play Knight D5 this just gets the
Knight out of the way for us to play the
move H5
now let's say they cast on the king side
we can take on uh G6 if they take now
all of a sudden we can push on the queen
side of the board and this Pawn is
protecting the pawn on C4 we can
eventually take with our Bishop you can
also see because the pawn on the f file
for Black is gone if we ever get our
Bishop to C4 and control this long light
Square diagonal here that's going to put
our opponent under a lot of pressure so
that's just something to keep in mind as
far as why we're playing A4 we've
already put pressure on the king side of
the board and we still have the
semi-open file with our Rook on H1 so
we're just going to be continuously
putting pressure on our opponent and yes
they do have their Rook on the semi-open
file on the file but typically when you
do that you want to have your pawns on
G7 and H7 it's not very secure if you
can see the king
all of a sudden there's a lot of air in
front of it the pawn on G6 is already
pushed up so this is not a safe King by
any means now if we come back and say
what if they don't play Bishop 2 G7 What
If instead or after they play
um after we play H4 they decide to play
B4
okay well now we can push forward with
E5 attacking the knights
if they want to exchange because they
definitely have that option we're fine
with that we could take on F6 if they
want to take on B2 we can take Bishop on
B2 they can take our pawn and we can
recapture with our Bishop on C4 now the
reason I said earlier is we may not care
about castling is they could play Bishop
B4 in this spot and that's fine with us
because we could play King F1 our Rook
on H1 is not trapped instead we can just
keep pushing forward protecting it with
this Rook it can easily get involved
into the game King to F1 is completely
fine with us that's going to be
different than the next variation that
we'll look at here in a minute but
that's why
white is completely okay they have the
bishop on B2 and C4 eyeing down on the
king side of the board you can see that
from black standpoint their Pawn
structures aren't great on the queen
side they have an isolated Pawn on C6
here they can Castle on the king side if
they want to but white just has so much
material they can throw at them so it's
going to be very difficult for black to
hold on to the position
the next version we're going to look at
instead of playing G6 they could play B4
attacking our Knight now we could always
play A4 but this is not the approach we
want to take in my opinion we want to be
fairly aggressive keep things in the
center of the board and always be
attacking bring our Knight to A4 this
night's pretty much out of the game here
and we also don't want to just move the
same piece over and over if we
eventually get it to C5 at some point
not really the strategy I like to go
instead we have the move E5 this is also
at Magnus Carlson played at a major
tournament where he dominated so I feel
like if it's good enough for him it
should be good enough for us as well so
E5 puts a lot of pressure on our
opponent yes they're attacking our
Knight so they could go ahead and take
we're going to capture and they have
some options here they could go ahead
and take down here on B2
we can just recapture with our Bishop
and then if they take our Pawn we can
Castle on the king side the reason we
cast on the king side if you say well
why don't we just take this Pawn on C4
if we take this a little bit different
than the instance that we looked at
previously where our Pawn was on H4 in
this position we actually don't mind
castling on the king side that would be
the best approach to get our Rook on H1
involved into the game but now they can
play Bishop B4 now we're in a tough spot
because now we play King to F1
and we don't really just want to play H4
now because the king side of the board
for black isn't as weak and so this is
not as good of a position and so instead
of taking on C4 which we could do
eventually I think castling on the king
side first makes a ton of sense now they
may decide you know what I don't want to
take here on B2 because that just gives
them an opportunity to recapture and get
their dark Square Bishop involved into
the game a lot of players don't like to
do that so instead they could just take
with their Pawn on F6
if that's the case we're just going to
take with our pawn and they could play
Queen to a five remember we haven't
castled yet this pins down our Pawn to
the king but we can still just castle
and this is a trap and the reason I like
to go ahead and Castle here because if
they take with their Queen on C3 this
would be a huge mistake
now the reason it's a mistake is because
white has the move Bishop D2 and we're
able to really put a ton of pressure on
our opponent a few things you'll notice
one is the queen right now is fairly
trapped there's only two squares that
they can go to you have a B2 you can
come to A3 but also you can see the king
is still exposed here in the center of
the board and that's going to come into
play as well black also doesn't have
other material that's developed that can
help in this game so from here I think
black's gonna play Queens A3 probably
the best way to get the king or the the
queen out of Harm's Way now we can start
gobbling up material yes they capture
that pawn on C3 but now we can start
capturing with more threats than our
opponent has so Bishop takes on C4
attacking the pawn on F7
and this Pawn right now is only defended
by the king also this opens up for our
Rook to come to E1 putting more pressure
on our opponents really black needs to
be thinking about how they can get their
King to safety so maybe bishop E7
blocking off any attack if we come to E1
which we are going to play we're gonna
play Rook to E1 and they could Castle on
the king side now we're gonna play Rook
E3 this attacks the queen
so the queen needs to come up to you
know D6 I'm showing the best moves from
black they don't have to they could
completely fall apart and then we just
easily take more of their uh material
but now we can play Queen E1
really attacking this bishop on E7 so
how do they respond from here well they
have two options one they can play Rook
to E8 which is a huge mistake trying to
control it or they could play Bishop to
d8 so let's look at both of those
options the first one being the huge
mistake it looks logical yes you you
have your Rook here defending the bishop
and the Queen
but now we have the move Bishop B4
attacking the queen right here it's
defended by our own Queen here on E1 so
what do they really do
you know they could give up material if
they wanted to but at the end of the day
they're going to need to move their
Queen yes the queen is still defending
but we have an additional Defender now
on this E7 Square so we're going to win
The Exchange because we've added that
Bishop to the mix so even if we exchange
right here you can see we are now up in
the minor piece game and it should be a
pretty easy in-game for us
now if we come back instead of playing
Rook to E8 which I think is a huge
mistake they could just play Bishop d8
now you can start to see that black is
being in defensive mode they're just
bringing their Bishops back to the
eighth rank they're not involved into
the game at all
and this is going to be difficult for
them to play extremely well they're just
going to be defending and they're in a
tough spot especially because we still
have the move Bishop B4 attacking this
queen pinning it down to the Rook
definitely needs to move the queen and
we can just take after they take here we
can play Queen C3 and they are in a
tough spot we can get our other Rook
involved into the game uh we're
controlling the center of the board they
don't have a lot of good options so
really depends on where they move with
their Queen but if they take that pawn
on C3 they're in for a world of hurt
the last option we are going to look at
is instead of playing Pawn 2 B4
attacking our Knight what if they play
Bishop to B7 trying to control this
light squared agonal after we played our
move Pawn E4 from here we're going to
stay pretty aggressive and play E5
and then after Knight to D5 we have the
tricky move E6 now this is somewhat of a
trap because if they take that would be
a huge mistake but even if they don't
take they're in a tough spot so first
let's look at what happens if they take
we can play Knight to G5 this opens up a
lot one because they've moved the pawn
from the F7 Square
we can now play Bishop 2 H5 at some
point attacking the king but we're also
attacking the pawn on E6 so how do they
defend that because right now we have
one attacker it's kind of awkward if
they move their Bishop back to C8 now
they've moved it to B7 moved it back
just to defend it and they have a
weakened King side they're not going to
be able to Castle on the king setting
time soon because the bishop on f8 is
pretty blocked off they can't move their
E7 Pawn easily so that's kind of a tough
spot and then from here we can start
pushing on the queen side putting max
pressure on our opponent so that's not
very good if they do something else
maybe Queen
to D7
okay well now we can just play Bishop G4
getting more material involved attacking
the pawn on E6 now they have no real
good way to defend this unless they want
to bring their Bishop back here but even
still we can take because they can't
take what they're leading Queen here we
could take it with our Knight so we can
still get more material involved and
they just don't have a good way to
defend this so that would be a terrible
option but if they don't take on E6
really the best move for them because
we're coming in hot we are playing Pawn
takes on F7 check and then they are in a
world of hurt so really they need in
this position play F6 but as soon as
they play F6 this still opens up at some
point we have the threat of the bishop
coming to H5 so just keep that in mind
first we're gonna play A4
attacking this Pawn if they play B4
which makes logical sense we're
attacking and then they want to continue
to attack and not just lose this Pawn
right here on B5 because then we can
start to chip away at the structure on
the queen side but we have the tricky
move now on Knight to H4 they may think
why are you just giving up this night
here but again we're always trying to
look for ways to put our opponent's
tough spot where if they don't know the
position they can make a big mistake and
if they take here we have that opening
that we talked about and that is the
bishop to H5
now the only option that they have in
this bot is to play G6
but now we just take with our Knights
and they can't just take with their Pawn
because if they do that's going to be
Checkmate so that would be a huge
mistake obviously you can see this Pawn
on E6 is doing so much work here
so really if you look at the options
that they have
Bishop G7 makes some sense okay but now
we have the move Queen C2 and this puts
him in a tough spot now if they were to
play let's say Rook to G8 because
they're Rooks on our attack this
actually falls and this would be
checkmate
anytime we move our Knights it's going
to be a discovered attack so maybe
Knight H4 this is check with our Bishop
how do they respond remember we have our
queen that can easily come into the game
maybe they try to play uh King f8
remember they're in check here okay well
now we take with our Queen on H7 maybe
they play Knight F4 doesn't really
matter we're gonna come up here Knight
to G6 check they could take yes but we
take with her Queen and how do they stop
the Checkmate from coming they
absolutely can't so Rook to G8 again
there's a few other variations that
black could try to
make it last one or two moves later but
the end of the day they are going to
lose if they don't play Rook to G8
though
house do they respond maybe F5 trying to
block the queen from getting into the
game
but the queen just takes okay maybe that
opens up the door for the night to come
to F6 does that help well no it doesn't
because now we can just take with their
Knight on h8 and they can't recapture
because remember as soon as the Knight
moves it's a check it's discovered
attack from the bishop on H5 they're in
a ton of uh pain and so they maybe play
King to f8 get out of check Knight to F7
this is a pretty difficult Outpost for
them to deal with yes we're attacking
their Queen and they can come down
capture on D4 but after we Castle they
don't have a lot of threats here their
Rook on A1 isn't doing much they're
Knight on B8 and even their Bishop on B7
it's gonna take some time for them to
get involved into the game this bishop
on G7 hit fan ghetto here and eventually
wanted to do something it's not doing
anything at all and so you can see from
White standpoint we have a pretty good
game here we can get our dark Square
Bishop involve into the game we can get
both of our Rooks involved trying to
control the center if we want to but
this is the power of the Geller Gambit
against the slop is it really puts our
opponent in some tough spots so that is
the slav Geller game but hopefully you
guys enjoy this video if you played the
if you play the Queen's Gambit and you
play against the slob I definitely think
you should check this out so thank you
guys so much for watching the video I'll
see you guys next time